là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais regarder
la france au fond des yeux
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils apprennent à
tricoter d'accord là-dessus à votre
place la rame et non un peu moins mais
si vous ne réussissez pas c'est qu'il
vous manque qu'une seule chose quant aux
petits détails et bienvenue dans
l'inattendu comme chaque semaine france
info et l'ina vous offre un voyage dans
le temps à travers les archives de la
télévision
pour mieux comprendre l'actualité
contemporaine à mes côtés tariq ali et
ludivine lopez journaliste à la
rédaction de l'ina bonjour à tous les
deux alors vous avez sélectionné deux
archives qui trouve un écho particulier
avec l'actualité tahri vous c'est un
témoignage entendu lundi dans la
matinale de france inter qui a retenu
votre attention celui d'une femme
une survivante ouïghours et c'est ça
cette fameuse s'appelle golbert haïti où
agit elle publie ce mercredi un livre
aux éditions équateur ce livre c'est
rescapé du goulag chinois le premier
témoignages d'une survivante ouïgours
alors pour rappel les ouigours c'est
cette minorité musulmane de chine qui
est persécutée par le régime est donc
cette femme elle racontait non seulement
ces violences subies mais moi ce qui m'a
vraiment marqué dans son témoignage
c'est qu'elle nous parle de
stérilisation forcée pour les femmes
ouïghours il se trouve que dans nos
archives en 1999 un reportage nous
racontait le même la même pratique dans
les petites communautés de la diaspora
ouïgoure d'asie centrale
on retourne souvent le couteau dans la
plaie on évoque la répression les
tortures infligées par la police
chinoise
pire encore les abus du planning
familial communiste on pratique la
stérilisation forcée sur des centaines
de milliers de nos femmes
nos mères et nos soeurs sont emmenés à
l'hôpital de force pour subir des
avortements
[Musique]
on jette des milliers de foetus aux
ordures voilà vous avez entendu à des
pratiques assez atroce n'y a pas d'autre
mot et ça fait des décennies que ça dure
à tout autre sujet avec vous un ludivine
vous allez nous parler de la
reconstitution d'une grotte
préhistorique absolument extraordinaire
oui il s'agit de la grotte cosquer situé
sous la mer entre marseille et cassis
elle est inaccessible donc une réplique
comme pour la sco est actuellement en
cours de réalisation
l'ouverture au public a été annoncée
pour 2022
en tout cas quoi qu'il en soit cette
actualité m'a fait penser à une archive
un reportage diffusé à l'époque sur
antenne 2 au moment de l'ouverture par
en tout cas de la découverte de la
grotte avec cette interview l'interview
d'henri cosquer c'était en 1991
depuis dix mille peut-être quinze mille
ans ces calanques de cassis garder un
secret un joyau paléolithique une des
plus belles grottes ornées du monde 250
m de poudreuse et le plongeur spéléo
débouche au sec dans une salle de
plusieurs dizaines de mètres de diamètre
extraordinaire le sol est humide mais
les décors rupestres sont intactes
inventeur de la grotte
henri cosquer le président du club de
plongée de cassis est encore émerveillé
par le spectacle c'est là en faisant les
photos je tombais sur une
une même peine c'est là que j'ai
découvert des chevaux des chevaux peine
et des bisons chevret servent les
oiseaux c'est unique en son genre
c'est une découverte d'envergure
mondiale déjà classé par jack lang il
vient de lui donner le nom de grottes
henri cosquer la grotte cosquer est
classée aux monuments historiques
vivement ont pu découvrir sa réplique
on a hâte merci beaucoup voilà pour
l'actualité de cette semaine
mais que s'est il passé le 13 janvier à
travers le temps regardez le zapping de
l'ina ça s'est passé à 13 janvier
bonjour dehors par moins cinq il faut
avoir du courage
c'est sans doute pourquoi reporters et
photographes sont allées chez le bistrot
du coin assister à la conférence de
presse que leur a faite jacques charrier
à l'occasion de la naissance de son fils
nicolas pensez donc le bébé de bébé pour
la première fois puis 936 on vient
d'abaisser la durée légale du travail
trente neuf heures au lieu de 40 eur et
39 heures s'est dit dans le texte leur
donnant ce dans la perspective de la
semaine de 35 heures en 1987 henri
langlois est mort la nuit dernière à son
domicile d'une crise cardiaque
il avait 62 ans écoutez le parler de
cinéma car on a appelé ça la machine du
rêve vous savez la machine à fabriquer
des rêves mais c'est pas réalité c'est
pas une machine à fabriquer des rêves
c'est beaucoup plus fort que ça c'est le
rêve qui s'exprime au travers le cinéma
c'est d'après midi à paris un millier de
personnes ont manifesté pour apporter
leur soutien aux quelques dizaines de
paysans du larzac venue dans la capitale
protester contre l'extension d'un camp
militaire dans leur région on peut pas
se douter je pense que la télévision
allait passer onze films par semaine qui
est quand même une chose criminelle et
surtout de passer trois films le
vendredi soir car le vendredi soir quand
même c'est le meilleur jour et pour le
cinéma et pour le théâtre donc je pense
que tous les acteurs aussi bien de
théâtre de cinéma sont concernés au
total l'intervention a duré 17 heures
pour la réussir pas moins de dix-huit
chirurgien épaulé par une cinquantaine
de spécialistes internationaux se sont
relayés dans le bloc opératoire
j'aime la vie ça m'embête beaucoup le
voir que la porte arrivée qu'il va
falloir la l'apache est très désagréable
bonsoir c'est l'un des personnages de
bandes dessinées les plus connus au
monde tintin devrait étendre encore un
petit peu plus sa notoriété sa légende
ce jeudi tarik lors d'une vente aux
enchères lui une vente aux enchères qui
nous fait que tintin le petit globe
trotter est estimé entre 2 et 3 millions
d'euros sur cette couverture du lotus
bleu la couverture initiale pourquoi
initial n'est pas original tout
simplement parce que ce n'est pas cette
image que l'on retrouve sur l'album qui
a été publié donc je vous dise entre 2
et 3 millions d'euros
et ça pourrait s'élever au delà puisque
vous l'avez dit et les mises aux
enchères alors sa part incroyable des
millions d'euros pour une planche de
bande dessinée pourtant rien ne
prédestinait tintin à atteindre une
telle valeur non on peut dire que
c'était inattendu un puce
un peu facile vous la corde mais c'est
parce que si on écoute hergéen son
auteur nous parler de ce petit
personnage qui est apparue la première
fois en 1929 dans le magazine belge le
petit vingtième
si on les écoute eh ben on a
l'impression que voilà on va pas lui est
publiée à lui destiné un tel avenir on
va écouter rg sur le plateau d'
apostrophes du mai du grand bernard
pivot c'était en 1979
comme je savais très mal décidé je suis
très très très mal et que je me disais
que j'allais tout même duré quelques
semaines j'ai je me suis contenté de
faire un petit rond un cercle petite
mèche pour donner un accent comme ça
j'étais certain que ce personnage dont
le reconnaîtrai de décès en dessin et de
semaine en semaine
voitures et plus prévoir un tel avenir
92 ans après sa naissance
eh ben il a fêté son anniversaire lundi
c'est la journée mondiale du tintin
d'ailleurs tintin est toujours là il n'a
pas pris une ride 250 millions d'albums
vendus est un succès qui va bien au-delà
des simples amateurs de bande dessinée
un puisqu'il bouleverse depuis quelques
années le monde de l'art et celui des
enchères oui et ça on peut le dater avec
précision c'est décembre 1990 la
première vente
remarquez d'objets
lié à l'univers de tintin à des albums
au 6 décembre 1990 on en parle dans le
jt d'antenne de bruno masure avec une
pointe de faire casser tenant ils ont de
7 à 77 ans on les appelle tintin aux
filous tintane aux maniaques les
amoureux du petit vais-je aux culottes
de golf était aujourd'hui plus de 15
cents à se disputer aux enchères 500
lots dédiés à leur idole en chair record
pour une couverture en couleurs des
cigares du pharaon plus de 3 millions de
francs c'est l'une des très rares
couverture dessinée en couleur par hergé
lui-même c'est donc le cigare le plus
cher du monde 3 millions 200 mille
francs 3 millions 200 mille francs est l
équivalent aujourd'hui d'environ 750
5000 euros alors là le prix qui
interpelle dans cette archive évidemment
mais est-ce que vous avez vu qu'ils
étaient dans la salle
au premier rang j'ai de cette gloire aux
enchères eh bien on va voir ce n'est pas
vraiment un amateur de cigares en tout
cas très gros fumeur amateurs ont dit
interne au fil d'un teen au film un
jeune cpom j'aurais tendance à dire j'ai
un petit nouveau film je regardais
tradis major renouant tintinophiles d'un
tintin nos fils comment bouger mes
poubelles
renault qui est très adepte de bandes
dessinées de tintin en particulier et
nous parle de cette passion en 1992 vous
allez voir sa bibliothèque
elle donne le vertige
tous ces albums que j'ai maintenant n'a
beaucoup certains quand beaucoup
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui que j'ai eu à
l'état neuf dans les mains que j'ai
colorier déchiré jeter maltraités et du
noir dans les mains je savais pas de
l'or dans les mains c'est peu de le dire
puisque 24 ans après cette archive en
2016 renault a vendu une double planche
de tintin pour un montant seulement de 1
million 500 mille euros
rien que ça je vais peut-être sortir
mais mettant en cause les est de 50
aucun problème des prix qui paraît ce
dingue en tout cas comment est ce qu un
simple personnage de bande dessinée peut
atteindre de tels montants talent parce
que tintin
il est connu dans le monde entier c'est
une madeleine un peu pour des
générations et des générations
tintin ça ne raconte pas une époque mais
des époques leur valeur comme temps aux
soviets tintin tous les albums en
afrique et tout ça ça raconte vraiment
des valeurs historiques presque et
surtout la rareté de certaines pièces
les les éditions originales des objets
dérivés un peu rare des dessins non
publiés tout ça ça attise la convoitise
de tous les collectionneurs des
collectionneurs du monde entier et donc
oui vente après vente les enchères sa
folle elle s'envole
c'est l'un des chiffres du jour 764 1200
euros c'est le montant d'une gouache
originale de tintin en amérique qui a
été adjugé lors d'une vente cet après
midi à paris pulvérisant ainsi le record
mondial pour un original de bande
dessinée c'est un nouveau record la
couverture signée hergé de tintin en
amérique a été adjugée aujourd'hui 1,3
million d'euros 2 millions cinq cent dix
neuf mille euros c'est à ce prix qui a
été adjugé aux enchères cet après midi
chez artcurial une planche de tintin
dessiné par hergé
c'est un nouveau record battu deux
millions cinq cent dix neuf mille euros
vertige ça donne le vertige d'autant que
figurez vous que c'est leur corps mon
temps pour un dessin de bd vendu aux
enchères et un record qui pourrait être
battus à cette semaine dans une vente
donc avec le fameux dessin dont nous
avait parlé celui du lotus bleu merci
beaucoup knight cela fait peut-être
partie de vos bonnes résolutions prises
le 1er janvier plus une goutte d'alcool
pendant un mois ça s'appelle le dry
d'ingénierie littéralement janvier à sec
un mois sans alcool une initiative
encouragée par les autorités de santé
publique qui rappelle que l'alcool et
les maladies que cela provoque tu
jusqu'à quarante et une 1000 personnes
chaque année en france une pathologie
souvent associé aux hommes importants
elles touchent de plus en plus de femmes
bonjour clair tout ça alors vous êtes
l'auteur de sans alcool c'est plus qu'un
livre 1 c'est un témoignage c'est votre
témoignage c'est votre histoire
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à vous
ouvrir ainsi ben je pense que justement
j'ai écrit ce livre parce que j'avais
envie de mettre une tête sympathique
j'espère sur la sobriété
parce que moi j'ai il m'a manqué des
modèles il m'a manqué des récits en fait
à part celui de mon conjoint dont je
parle dans le livre sur les bienfaits de
la sobriété
c'est vrai que plus que tu fustigés
l'alcool où la consommation d'alcool
parce que pour moi tout le monde est
libre de faire ce qu'il veut j'avais
envie de dire la sobriété aussi ça peut
être super si vous avez des problèmes de
dépendance par exemple alors à travers
votre rue si vous vous levez le voile
sur l'alcoolisme féminin un sujet qu'on
dit tabou important il est évoqué depuis
longtemps à la télévision ludivine
exactement c'est ce que j'ai constaté en
regardant les archives que m'a proposé
notre documentaliste anne delavaux en
fait ce qui ressort c'est vrai que avec
ce que j'ai vu il est difficile de dire
que l'alcoolisme féminin est un sujet
tabou à la télévision parce que depuis
longtemps il y à des reportages des
émissions entières consacrées au sujet
et ça depuis les années 60 avec des
témoignages de femmes des femmes que
j'ai observé d'un milieu plutôt modeste
en tout cas c'est ce qui ressort des
premiers témoignages et surtout c'était
des femmes qui se livrait à visage caché
comme ici en 1962 dans la célèbre
émission cinq colonnes à la une le
journaliste pierre dumayet assistait à
une réunion des alcooliques anonymes et
il y avait des femmes
je suis la police il ya environ dix ans
que j'ai commencé en drap je vivais un
verre deux verres je vomissais je vais
recommencer jusqu'à ce que je puisse
garder tout ça toujours en cachette en
cachette de bout de mes enfants de mon
mari qui ne se rendent pas compte de
tout ça vous voyez que j'étais anormal
mais ne savait pas exactement ce qu'il a
mais je pense qu'on a énormément de
volonté pour dissimuler sa vous l'avoir
entendu en clair tout hasard en 1962
cette femme évoquait la honte d'être
alcoolique sa volonté de dissimuler à sa
famille à ses proches sa maladie est-ce
que vous aussi vous avez caché votre
votre addiction
je pense qu'on n'a jamais fiers d'être
addict que ce soit homme ou femme de
toute façon c'est quelque chose qu'on
essaie de cacher après je pense que dans
les années 60 les femmes beaucoup de
femmes au foyer par exemple buvait et
sans cacher c'était extrêmement tabou
je le mets d'ailleurs dans le livre on
disait que par exemple quand elle
mourrait on sait qu'elle mourrait en
fait de crise cardiaque et jamais
d'alcoolisme
ce qui était extrêmement triste en fait
c'étaient des femmes qui se cachait en
fait le sujet était tabou mais
principalement au milieu d'eux dans les
familles en fête c'est toi la famille
c'est un oui mais je pense que ça l'est
toujours
de toute façon c'est tabou en france de
l'alcoolisme femme ou homme parce que
personne n'a envie de se définir
alcoolique et en fait si nous mêmes on
se définit alcoolique déjà en phase on
dira peut-être que nous aussi on a un
problème est scolarisé un cerveau est ce
qu'on arrive à se définir justement
alcoolique de de se juger et d'établir
un diagnostic personnel tout simplement
après il ya des ems par exemple donne
des tests qui peuvent vous montrer en
fait quel est votre degré d'alcoolisme
mais je pense que c'est quelque chose
d'assez personnel parce qu'on peut
complètement explosé les scores pardon
sur une application de plus de deux
verres par soir par exemple est ce dire
non mais ça va je suis bon vivant je
pense que ça passe par des phases de se
regarder en face en fête et se dire est
ce que j'ai un problème ou pas ça passe
par voilà par une évaluation personnelle
de la situation en tout cas on parlait
de la honte tout à l'heure c'est un
sentiment qui revient souvent dans les
récits de femmes alcoolique en 1973
cette autre dame en parlait elle
expliqué pourquoi elle avait honte
finalement sur le plateau de l'émission
les dossiers de l'écran consacré au
drame de l'alcoolisme
peut-être que nous nous sentons plus
jugé que les hommes vous rencontrez un
qui a une cuite vous dites vous trouvé
ça assez drôle une femme qui a une
cuisse on veut on est moins aimables
avec elle claire touzard ce sentiment
d'être plus jugé qu'un homme est ce que
c'est toujours une réalité aujourd'hui
en tout cas ce qui a changé je pensais
que la pop culture et la culture c'est
beaucoup emparé du sujet récemment je
pense aux séries par exemple je pense
même au film où on a beaucoup vu les
femmes boire en fait boire seul entre
autres et aussi à boire comme si c'était
une sorte de symbole d'émancipation un
peu et je pense que du coup ça a dû un
peu changé les mentalités il ya une plus
grande visibilité des femmes qui boivent
après à ce que au jour le jour
c'est bien vu moi en tout cas on n'a
jamais fait de réflexion parce que
j'étais une femme on m'a fait une
réflexion parce que j'étais pas correct
parce que je buvais mais je pense qu'il
n'avait rien à voir avec mon sexe en
tout cas le jugement des femmes
alcoolique
ils et elles étaient assez évident dans
les années 70 vous allez le voir avec
cette archive voulez vous la montrer
parce qu'elle est assez évoquant tu dans
les années soixante dix quand on parlait
alcoolisme féminin à la télévision le
sujet beauté n'était jamais bien loin
une membre du comité national de défense
de défense contre l'alcoolisme en
parlait sur le plateau de l'émission
aujourd'hui madame en 1973
selon elle si une femme devait arrêter
de fumer de fumer de boire pardon c'est
une femme devait arrêter l'alcool
c'était aussi pour ça c'est bien je suis
doré dessus il est évident que l'alcool
atteint la beauté des femmes à beaucoup
de niveaux au niveau des conjonctive au
niveau du teint au niveau des dents de
la chevelure
il est évident également donc il n'y a
pas de beauté son joli tas nous avons un
tract au comité national qui s'appelle
sobriété joli teint sobriété joli temps
difficiles aujourd'hui ça vous inspire
quoi d'entendre ça car tout ça c'est
drôle parce que tous les interviews que
j'ai eu moi parce nous poser la question
une personne vraiment rapidement donc
quelque part finalement ça prouve que
c'est plus est plus d'actualité
concernant les femmes on pense tout
d'abord au bien-être je pense au
bien-être moral c'est un autre temps
finalement l'aspect beauté le parc on
n'oserait plus
aujourd'hui surtout après tout le
mouvement qui a eu sur droits des femmes
aujourd'hui actuellement le mythe ou que
de possession de ce genre de questions
moi les questions sont toujours liés
comme au bien-être bien-être physique
mais plutôt dans l'ordre de la forme et
de la santé que bien-être physique dans
votre livre vous dites 4 sobre et bien
plus subversif qu'on ne le pense
qu'entendez vous par là
en fait quand on arrête de boire on s'en
rend compte à quel point c'est être une
anomalie en france puisque tout le monde
boit en fait donc c'est quelque part
c'est subversif
c'est à dire quand j'ai arrêté de boire
j'ai eu énormément de réflexion de
personnes autour de moi pas forcément
malveillante mais qui comprenait pas
pourquoi je lâche et un peu le sport
national quelque part je suis gelé quand
on arrête de boire c'est bien sûr on est
isolé il faut toujours répondre faut
toujours se justifier en fait ce qui est
incroyable parce qu'on pourrait avoir le
droit et la liberté de ne pas voir mais
c'est comme si c'était vraiment encore
une fois une anomalie et qu'on était
toujours obligé de justifier notre choix
parce qu'en fait quelque part ça renvoie
un miroir à la personne en face et que
si on arrêtait de bord c'est un peu lui
dira peut-être que ce que tu fais n'est
pas terrible est ce que votre vie
sociale a changé entre le moment où vous
consommiez d'alcool et le moment où vous
avez arrêté
bien sûr on configure bon déjà il est le
confinement et c'est tous nos vies
sociales vont changer
après je pense qu'on re configure des
choses évidemment on n'a plus les mêmes
activités
on change de pratiques aussi parce qu'en
fait avant tout et très rythmée par
l'apéritif par le dîner
et c'est parfois l'apéro se transforme
en sport ou en balade en forêt et en
fait c'est pas plus mal c'est ludivine
on va on va revenir un peu dans le passé
avec vous vers la fin des années 70
alors là le profil des femmes alcoolique
qui témoigne à la télévision change
oui c'est ce que j'ai remarqué en
regardant les archives je l' ai dit tout
à l'heure les premiers témoignages
étaient plutôt ceux de femmes issues de
milieux modestes et à partir de la fin
des années 70 cela ce que l'alcoolisme
féminin change de visage des femmes de
milieux sociaux plus aisés se livre à la
télévision à l'image de l'auteur et
scénariste laure charpentier à visage
découvert elle était l'une des premières
à franchir le cap
c'était en 1977 j'avais des amis qui
buvaient on sortait j'ai commencé par
voir les jus de fruits puis après je me
suis dit je vais boire un peu de
champagne pourquoi pas j'ai bien de
champagne j'ai bien bu du whisky et puis
et puis j'ai l'habitude s'est créé tous
les soirs vous ressortez et c'était les
bouteilles de champagne bouteille de
whisky et cetera je suis catalogué comme
alcoolique monde n est là c'est parce
que ça n'avait rien de mondains c'était
des nuits blanches qui n'en finissait
pas d eau éternelle et malheureusement
des réveils traîne aux yeux très
difficile c'est l'une des premières fois
que le terme alcoolisme mondain est
utilisé à la télévision est évoquée en
tout cas vous en parlez aussi dans votre
livre clair tout ça et plus largement
c'est le rapport de la société à
l'alcool que vous questionnez oui le rat
par la cité à l'alcool il est
extrêmement ambigu parce qu'en fait on
pourrait se dire que quand même une
heure enfin surtout aujourd'hui en fait
à une époque où on remet tout en
question de l'empreinte carbone à notre
façon de consommer de manger etc
l'alcool lui toujours hâte sur un
sorcier enviable c'est qu'on lui remet
jamais en question
alors qui le crée beaucoup de souffrance
alors qu'ils créent des rapports de
domination accéléré et qu'on sait c'est
comme s'ils avaient plusieurs alcoolisme
et que l'on mettait un peu sous le tapis
les mauvais aspects l'alcool est ce que
l'alcoolisme mondain est plus développée
qu'on ne le dit en france aujourd'hui
l'alcoolisme mondain vous entendez
l'alcoolisme bond ce qu'on appelle
masquer la paix l'alcoolisme bon vivant
en fait c'est à dire boire comme un
expert
log je crois que beaucoup de gens se
cachent aussi leur consommation en en se
disant experts et en se disant analogue
parce que c'est un peu une carte
pratique les arts de la table
c'est-à-dire finalement je suis pas
alcoolique
si je bois une bouteille c'est juste
parce que je suis connaisseurs et que en
fait du coup par là on se cache un peu
nos excès et les conséquences de
l'alcool dans nos vies alors je dis pas
que l'alcool n'est pas un plaisir
certain
mais en fait la modération accélère pour
moi le plaisir est souvent on se perd un
peu
justement dans l'excès alors vous parlez
d'un autre aspect dans votre livre le
rôle de la pop culture vous l'avez
évoqué il ya quelques minutes dans la
banalisation de l'alcoolisme féminin
ça veut dire quoi banalisation je sais
pas mais c'est vrai que par exemple si
un problème en ce moment aucune afghan
bits
les problèmes d'alcool mais il ya
beaucoup de séries quand on regarde où
il est question de ça en fait du cougar
town a énormément comme si en fait pour
une femme boire c'était un peu un geste
politique presque en fait ça veut dire
montrer qu'on casse un peu les codes
conventionnels de la copie mais aussi
vous dites dans votre livre
bien sûr moi c'était une façon de me
rebeller notre guillemets et pour
beaucoup de femmes je crois que c'est
une façon de se rebeller de prendre un
peu d espace conte m'estime comme
masculin sauf qu'en fait ce qui est
triste in fine et c'est qu'on se fait du
mal donc en fait c'est pas une rébellion
très envié envie enfin un combat envie
en tout cas qu'en est il de la prise en
charge des femmes alcoolique ludivine à
partir de quand cette prise en charge a
commencé alors des groupes de paroles
telles que les alcooliques anonymes
accueille des femmes depuis longtemps on
l'a vu mais les premières structures
d'accueil spécialisés voient le jour à
la fin des années 70 il y avait celle ci
par exemple près de nantes une maison au
nom évocateur revivre des femmes entre
18 et 60 ans toutes catégories sociales
confondues accueillis et pris en charge
par d'anciennes alcoolique mais aussi
par des médecins et des psychologues
il y avait aussi des associations elle
voit le jour autour de cette période là
aussi comme sos alcool femmes en 1984
laure charpentier qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure dans l'archivé oui tout à
l'heure en était à l'initiative de cette
association au bois seul mais on ne
guérit pas seul de l'alcool donc il faut
accepter d'en parler il faut accepter de
trouver quelqu'un qui on parle avec vous
c'est un médecin c'est une personne
étrangère c'est un militant c'est je ne
sais pas qui mais c'est forcément
quelqu'un est ce quelqu'un il existe
alors l'amour l'amitié la main tendue et
et l'abstinence
vous vous retrouvez alors que j'ai écrit
dans mon livre enfin convoi seul mais on
ne guérit pas celle de l'alcool c'est ce
qu'elle dit ah ouais mais c'est
exactement ce que j'ai dans mon livre
j'ai guéri grâce à mon compagnon qui
lui-même avait arrêté qui m'a donné
envie d'arrêter de boire et je pense que
c'est vraiment par le mot et les paroles
des autres qu'on guérit donc je suis
complètement sur votre situation
aujourd'hui que vous apporte la sobriété
enfin franchement ça a changé ma vie
dans toutes les largeurs et c'est pour
ça que je trouve ça bien de pouvoir le
partager et de dire voilà c'est ça peut
être sympa aussi de ne pas boire ça
existe et pour ceux qui ont des
problèmes il faut il faut peut-être y
aller quoi lire tout ça remercie
beaucoup je rappelle le titre de votre
livre sans alcool publié chez flammarion
merci beaucoup à vous également ludivine
alors avant de refermer cette inattendue
un autre traditionnel pépite pour rendre
hommage à georges pernoud
notre confrère a disparu dimanche
pendant plus de quarante ans il a
incarné thalassa et vous vous souvenez
certainement de la musique du générique
de cette émission culte
bon vent à tous bonsoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
et bien sûr on se retrouve mercredi
prochain après le journal de 22 heures
sur le canal 27 et toute la semaine sur
les réseaux sociaux de france info et de
l'ina bonne semaine à tous
[Musique]